don't courage reduce film now I had a
bunch of nice questions I was going to
ask first but I want to go with the one
that I really just want to gather way
from the same question it's actually
it's a fun question fun flirty question
did you keep the prosthetics do you have
them somewhere at home maybe no no no I
think art director might have them yeah
okay as a souvenir
nice yeah I don't I don't have mine you
don't have yours keeps them up on the
wall like a lion's head yeah yeah it's
something to be proud of yeah it is and
I'm wondering how much work it was to
have them applied and I know that's
somewhat personal yeah you're not the
first I wasn't well you know honestly
like that's something that I was the
most nervous about when I read the
script and we Adam and I spoke we said
you know we're gonna wear these
prosthetics I actually was not nervous
but I mean obviously I was on some level
to wear this prosthetic but the applying
of the prosthetic was where my mind went
to first like what are the steps that go
into that because I don't want to make
anyone feel like they regret their life
yeah and and it's just you know and I
had my wife like talked to me before
like what do i do how do i anything I
should do like you know they it's it's a
lot of glue and so you just got to make
sure that it's um yeah it's a wonderful
it was a wonderful time sure very
delicately it was a strange time yeah
was a strange time in my life the nice
question now we'll go we'll go to the
professional questions or how did
Patrick get the script to the two of you
he got it to my wife Naomi and I love
years ago through Mark Duplass sent it
to us and then we loved it and then we
met Patrick and thought he was terrific
too and and just kind of went from there
and
tried to get it going and get the money
together and everything and and with
with the Duplass brothers and then and
then as we were getting closer to
shooting we got luckily got Jason to
agree to do it I was so I couldn't
believe I got this opportunity oh we
were so lucky to get I had a thing where
I was like literally this is too good
there's gotta be some catch that there
misses seeing something I was so excited
until I see would have to you mentioned
that you had a kinship with your
character only in that you felt the same
way when you came to LA you were sort of
a transplant and you want to reinvent
yourself oh yeah I'm wondering what your
advice to fellow actors would be you're
people that want to be in the industry
on coming from a small town and
reinventing themselves in the big city
you know staying with their career not
getting too caught up in the dinner
party life yeah yeah there's something
there's a real freedom to coming to a
new place where you don't know anybody
and you can just be whoever you want and
all those sort of ties to your past and
you're where you grew up and people's
perceptions of you are out the window
which is why I feel like Facebook is a
little damaging there they did a study
where they see that a lot of people who
go away to college or move to a new city
they're not there's not as much of the
kind of reinventing them so because on
Facebook you're still tied to right
everybody everybody's keeping track of
everything that everybody's doing and
you're still getting right comments from
your friends on everything you're doing
if you're in that engaged in it insist
at all there's not as much of that sort
of reinvention going on with people when
they go away to new places just as weird
what